men might have a a wild face when
they're younger like commit a few Petty
crimes climb some trees sneak out of the
house whatever but women we just like
get super into stuff and then we don't
and I understand why the men in the
manosphere are like oh God another woman
trying to do manosphere stuff I get it
because it's like we come in and we're
like oh cool and then we're like oh no
I'm a feminist again that's just that's
just what US ladies do we just you know
have faces even Tommy Lauren it was like
she was perfect Trad con chick lover
still a fan but like then what did she
do all of a sudden she was like
pro-choice and everyone's like and then
she did this men are trash rant we're
like Tommy what about this conservative
stuff well we have phases as women you
know how it is we just we just say